hey Katrina hey Greg have you have you
seen the channel tune sandwich the what
the channel tune Sam would tune the
sandwich well that's not ringing any
bells they do these trailer spoof so
they didn't want for endgame the day you
know it's the day it came out man that
took a while to me but it got really
liked it yeah they were already and
they're like these cartoon parodies of
the trailers are fair they they're
wonderful like hey they do a great J
it's just two people I think it's like a
husband a wife in Australia I'm
theorizing a lot of things but I'm
pretty sure she's a couple of people but
yeah they avail us react to their videos
and arts peer entertainment is their
channel oh cool I'm sure a little logo
between online and on fan Theory TV
let's get to it
it's baby spots
if you find this reporting don't feel
bad about this but don't be overly
thrilled about it either if there's an
afterlife I'm watching you Food Warmer
right now days ago
sparkling water that is I have enough
still water for a further six months I'd
rather dive and touch it go over that
[Laughter]
the 26 year old less storage fool delete
files to free up space what when did you
stop recording up for three hours
[Music]
[Music]
Oh that'll stick exactly the cinemas
gonna do which is more than I can say
for you Steve
that laundry top is still dripping I've
called a plumber but it's coming out of
your pain
[Music]
three guys in China tablet it okay that
was those Clint 50% of humanity was
wiped out that wasn't enough for you
they said they said I was too old for
this haircut you
I keep telling everybody she hahahaha
you read I don't think yeah well we
bristle we see we simmer missed you we
saw that's not us Steve that's just you
hence why we started calling and
grievance Stephen green this is gonna
work Stephen I know it is cuz they've
already announced spider-man - Black
Panther - yeah it's from three weeks ago
yeah born and started watching own teams
I switched back to the live stream Oh
cheesy still there and say this for him
he's tenacious why haven't you good a
minute because we just had this building
fumigated I don't want to bringing a
million of these six legged bunnies in
here plus he's a criminal
[Music]
to wait until they can we need something
that will distract Thanos for at least
40 minutes but it's boat
[Music]
that's an eraser you idiot oh hey I
haven't met those yet so maybe take that
into consideration before you call me an
idiot
trust me this day we kill each other
thanks to that triple shot
I require strongly hit
[Music]
okay dad you didn't like my friends at
school I'm sure it's a little like
Noby did you come to help your old Paul
but the harvest father what is this
natto so thin for you the best he can
hope to do is slow down or even damage
your sexy thick body oh well I
accomplished my mission so I stopped
hitting the gym I'm a farmer now carrots
spuds and sweets well the enemy is the
weather a cold snap wiped out half my
crop this winter we still have to fight
him yeah it don't seem fair anymore take
that this really takes the shine of
adventure you do whatever it takes to
subscribe to this channel cuz all it
takes is one click some people move on
before the video gets to the very end
but not us we linger we order we look
nothing we should make a public
announcement yeah what needs to know
that we're still here and we're gonna
know the world needs to drink lots of
your cult cuz then I wiped out half the
good bacteria in our guts Steve why are
you crying
cuz it's always the good ones you know
yeah well what did you think okay that
was so much fun
you gotta watch just two of them I heard
yeah I think so I think it's just those
two that's crazy
I heard you snicker laugh even till the
very last frame they console I love that
community what's cool about their videos
is that there's always little nuggets a
little Easter eggs that you'll have to
pick up on but you just might not have
time to oh that one where it's weird
Scott Lang is walking by this is
probably dusted by that house we did
are you in the night before 7:00 I love
that attention to detail on it because
there is that thing I'm like well she's
probably just dusted whoever's is
missing right I would love for these
guys to do a full-on parody of the movie
now I mean not like their own take on
like a condensed yeah I would love to
see that just based off of this alone
because they were just going off
trailers by the time they made this they
didn't get a chance to see the movie yet
so you know things really well that's
not who's in the movie you know actually
fairly early on yeah so it'd be cool to
see windows I mean there's gonna be some
time making the next one but man that's
I think they should do it geez David
Schwimmer I love the reoccurring bit of
like Chris Evans a single I this better
work I know cuz they hid out spider-man
2 black is so great such a great that
part made me laugh too were Hawkeye's
braiding Matt's hair yeah I love their
animation because they do look so much
like the actual characters you know and
it's easy to make them like this just
look really goofy but it impresses me to
them the amount of voices are all doing
some sound better than others but the
fact the feather doing all these voices
actually lends a cute charm to it I love
it I love it made fun of that because
you're like what the hell's that gonna
do
does this just let him in the movie
right when she's like shooting at the
target but even when you see that your
trailer like what's he shooting at who
she would the trailer makes me think
that it's all prepping to go up against
the a knows you're like what what are
you gonna do what's that bullet gonna do
to Thanos you're nothing they didn't
really really make a joke about that
here but I loved their visual bits they
they take advantage of the fact that
their style is animation so they have a
lot of visual cues and it's one of those
things where you can't slow it down and
get more from it
these guys are great they're hilarious
please fun I'm gonna have to watch more
please subscribe to them have it there
they're just killing
there was a tattoo it says I've done it
yeah yeah good
1.2 million followers I started watching
these guys when they were like 200,000
followers so I'm so happy for
congratulations you guys are so cool
killing it keep up the hard work you
guys are sexy I subscribe to the reject
nation subscribed to arts for
entertainment check out Katrina
Alicia Keys over at her Instagram and
deep Twitter I do have Twitter she
tweets I think but more importantly fan
through TV YouTube channel go check her
out as soon as you can we'll catch you
guys soon
they [ __ ] it up